Une question mais, mais, comment ils vont eux ?
Bonjour je *petite Marie je parle de*
ah oui la moustache ouais je sais ça fait un peu bizarre au début mais quand on s'y habitue
on se rend compte que ça me va assez bien
Faux!
Parfois dans la vie tu tombes sur le truc cool avec lequel faut absolument que tu te prenne en photo
la lumière est parfaite, ce jour là tu as mis tes meilleurs sapes, t'es bien coiffé, t'es au max
toutes les conditions sont réunies pour faire la photo insta parfaite à un détail près :
ton pote qui prend la photo sait pas faire les photos
- Comment on enlève le flash ?
alors soit il en a rien à foutre
- Évidemment que je serai là vendredi chez Nikos, y'a 250 personnes
soit il sait pas cadrer
- Alors qu'est ce que t'en penses ?
alors elle est pas mal il manque juste mon visage quoi
soit sans faire exprès il fait ce truc hyper énervant avec son doigt
ah tiens c'est marrant y'a ton doigt qui gâche la photo
soit il met cinq ans à faire la photo et toi tu vis un moment bien gênant
- Voilà nickel ne bougez pas
en carré ça sera mieux, voilà super, comme ça je vous ai bien
Je mets le flash
- Ça y est là non ?
Ah putain et je suis en mode selfie comment tu  retournes la caméra ?
- T'as bientôt fini ou pas ?
j'ai un peu mal aux bras là
ou alors tout simplement il a juste aucun talent
et ce qu'il fout la rage c'est que toi tu traînes avec ce pote qui te fais des photos nulles en permanence
alors que toi tu lui fais des pures photos qu'il mérite pas du tout
ouais j'ai des vrais problèmes dans la vie ok
bon après des fois c'est toi qui prends la photo mais c'est le modèle qui est chiant ça ça arrive
assez souvent
- En vertical s'il te plaît
- Vertical ?
- Une en horizontale
- Celle là on l'a déjà faite, tu l'a re-veut  quand même?
- Essaye de bien m'avoir hein
- Y'en a beaucoup on va pas se mentir
- Attends j'en fait une où je sourit
- Je crois que le musée est en train de fermer là, mais c'est pas grave.
- Vu que je suis un peu petit tu peux te baisser un peu s'il te plaît ? Voilà
Juste une dernière ok juste une dernière
Et le pire c'est que ce mec qui t'as demandé de prendre 1 000 photos absolument identiques
te demande de choisir laquelle tu préfères
non mais attends mais j'hallucine
à ce moment là dans ta tête tu joues au jeu des 7 différences
- La main !
- Bah évidemment mais la question c'est de savoir c'est laquelle tu préfères entre les deux
- Ah ça ?
ça je sais pas
quand on prend une photo à 2, y'a toujours une petite bataille
parce qu'on se trouve pas forcément beau sur les mêmes
et dans ces moments là il y'a toujours de la mauvaise foi c'est inévitable
- Hé mon gars on est tous les deux beaux gosses là
- Ouais ouais tous les deux
sauf, sauf moi mais, mais tous les deux beaux gosses ouais
des fois quand je vois le compte insta d'une influenceuse
je me dis "putain elle a vraiment une vie de rêve, ses photos insta elles tuent, elle est super belle,
son mec il doit avoir trop de la chance quoi"
- Mais rapproche toi faut qu'on voit le smoothie
mais rapproche toi tu comprends pas ce que te dis !?
En plus c'est dégueulasse
- Je t'aime
- Vas-y je m'en fout
quand tu veux faire une photo de groupe
la personne qui est désigné pour prendre la photo c'est toujours celui ou celle qui est un peu moins pote avec les autres tu sais
- Et si on prenait une belle photo ensemble ?
- Grave
- Qui va prendre la photo?
Tiens vas-y Norman
- Bah pourquoi moi attend je vais pas être dessus
- Bah tu les prends bien - En plus t'es grand
- J'sais pas, fin'
t'es pas trop notre pote en plus, on t'aime pas
- Bon ça va alors, allez serrez vous soyez très amis hein
très très amis voilà
vous pensez à pas me l'envoyer
- Ok
moi j'aime pas les gens sur insta qui mettent une photo en ligne et qui font carrément un teaser de cette photo dans leur story
genre c'est vraiment l'événement du mois pour eux quoi
- Allez voir et likez ma toute dernière photos sur insta elle est clairement culte
- WAW! c'est parti
- je mange un yaourt
parfois tu crois être en intimité avec une personne sur snap tu envois des petites photos et des petits messages bien perso
et elle te répond "yes nous aussi on te fait un gros bisou"
gé-nial
bon tout le monde connaît la fameuse technique de se rajouter un petit emoji sur le visage pour cacher un bouton ou un petit défaut
après si la personne à qui tu parles t'envois ça là faut se poser des questions
peut-être que il a le syndrome de....
d'avoir des boutons
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo pensez à cliquer sur la cloche sur ma chaîne youtube pour recevoir toutes mes notifs directement bam!
dans votre salon ou dans votre
lieu de visionnage
et sinon mettez un petit thumb to the top si vous avez apprécié et puis sinon c'est tout
ciao!
*Petite marie je t'attends transi
Sous une tuile de ton toit*
- c'est bien ou pas ?
- non c'est pas ouf
- après je peux faire comme ça :
*petite Marie je t'attends transis, oyeah oyeah, petite Marie*
non non arrête c'est l'enfer
- après sinon je peux faire ça, c'est un morceau que j'ai inventé :